bonjour à tous et merci d'être au rendez
vous pour ce nouveau numéro de dimanche
en politique il y a une semaine la
moitié des sièges du sénat a été
renouvelé un nouveau visage qui
ressemble à l'ancien est la droite
conserve sa majorité dans cette
institution dont le rôle est de voter
les lois
348 sénateurs parfois taxé d' inutile
parfois taxé de conservateurs alors au
juste à quoi sert vraiment le sénat est
il encore utile faut-il leurs efforts
mais faut-il même le supprimer avec nous
sur ce plateau pour en parler ce matin
trois invités trois sénateurs elle
dominique verrien sénatrice udi de
lianes c'est votre deuxième mandat
bonjour bonjour c'est d'être avec nous
face avoue jérôme durain bonjour je vous
êtes sénateur ps de saône et loire vous
aussi vous avez été réélu dimanche
dernier et puis avec nous un nouveau
sénateur fabien genêt bonjour center udi
vous aussi élu en saône et loire
dimanche dernier je le disais élections
la semaine dernière la droite consolide
sa majorité ça va pas changer la vie des
français
on a même l'impression que c'est une
élection cas pas vraiment passionné les
citoyens pourquoi jérôme durain c'est
normal et c'est pas grave c'est une
élection qui se fait dans un cas très
particulier c'est pas le suffrage
universel direct sont de grands
électeurs désignés par les élus donc ça
passe un peu sous les radars ça n'avait
pas vues par la population et c'est ce
qui permet aussi au sénat d'assumer sa
spécificité dans la fabrication de la
loi dans le contrôle du gouvernement
d'être un peu en décalage avec les
grandes émotions les humeurs les
tumultes de la société et c'est pour ça
qu'on fait un travail différent donc
c'est pas finalement anormal que cette
élection ne passionne pas les foules
fabien genêt vous l'avez senti vous
pendant la campagne c'était une élection
qui n'était pas excitante si j'ose dire
comme ça vous savez les élections sont
un peu excitant pour ceux qui y
participent
parce qu'il ya du suspense parce que les
résultats ne sont jamais acquis à
l'avancé et donc il faut aller au
contact des électeurs et les électrices
et les électeurs pour les élections
sénatoriales
ce sont les grands électeurs nos
collègues conseillers municipaux
adjoints aux maires conseillers
départementaux régionaux et je crois que
c'est un moment
pourtant parce que c'est là où on peut
prendre des engagements face à ceux qui
vont voter pour vous et puis demain
lorsque on a la chance de pouvoir siéger
eh bien on doit être rendez-vous de ses
engagements donc une campagne c'est
toujours un moment important c'est vrai
que le grand public et est moins
sensibilisés mais je crois quand même
que la figure en particulier du
président larcher est une figure
maintenant très connu par le grand
public et nous avons fait campagne
d'ailleurs pour qu'il soit réélu jeudi
de lever rien la phrase qu'on entend
souvent quand on parle du sénat c'est
les sénateurs s'en sert à rien ce que
vous avez envie de dire qu'au contraire
le sénat est une chambre indispensable à
la démocratie
parfois c'est un le pendant d'une
assemblée nationale depuis le
quinquennat l'assemblée nationale est
alors déjà renouveler en intégralité
tous les 50 derniers directement
derrière le président de la république
pour pouvoir se faire réélire les
députés qui forment une grande majorité
pour le président de la république ont
besoin que celui ci soit réélu ça crée
un lien très fort entre le gouvernement
et l'assemblée liens que le sénat n'a
pas ce qui lui permet d'avoir un regard
totalement différent d'abord parce que
nous sommes élus par des grands
électeurs donc nous avons tous le regard
des collectivités territoriales qui est
un peu différent parce qu'ensuite nous
sommes renouvelé que par moitié donc on
fera pas de grandes vagues bleues roses
vertes et cetera donc une certaine
stabilité
et puis ce travail d'obligations
finalement de de négociation avec
l'assemblée nationale permet de
travailler les textes de façon un peu
décalé et comme le disait jérôme pas du
tout sous ni sous le feu des projecteurs
ni avec la pression médiatique que peu à
voir l'assemblée nationale donc nous
sommes au contraire très important et en
plus nous sommes élus sur six ans donc
aucun lien avec le quinquennat
jérôme durain je me tourne vers vous ont
sur les réseaux sociaux on a beaucoup de
sénateurs qui publie des photos j'ai
voté j'ai voté au final on le sait c'est
l'assemblée nationale quelles qu aient
le dernier mot en général est-ce que
c'est pas su se faire plaisir est
sénateur donc ça c'est pas du tout alors
d'abord
si vous nous demandez ce matin est ce
que vous voulez conserver le sénat parce
que vous êtes sénateur ou sénatrice
c'est pas le sujet le peuple est
souverain s'il faut changer les choses
et avoir un débat sur les institutions
et très sens d'une démocratie
s'il faut changer les choses on
échangera et senna n'est pas une chambre
conservatrice c'est une chambre de
tempérance ça n'est pas la même chose
c'est à dire qu' on n'est pas là pour
figer ce qui existe on est là pour avoir
un débat qui se déroule dans d'autres
termes que celui qui a lieu à
l'assemblée nationale alors c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas le dernier mot
mais quand il ya des commission mixte
paritaire 7 députés 7 sénateurs quand le
texte a été étudiée est en chacune des
deux chambres
souvent c'est la version du sénat qui
l'emportent pourquoi parce que à
l'assemblée nationale comme le disait
dominique vers ya un député une députée
procède du président de la république il
est finalement lié la dynamique
présidentielle donc il est lié par
politiquement à ce que fait le président
a dit nous on n'est pas dans cette
obligation de suivre le gouvernement
d'eau qu'on est forcément plus autonome
plus indépendant on peut se permettre
d'avoir des débats qui sont plus sur
l'intérêt général est en baisse et ça
sent la fin au final mais ça sur sarthon
que ça sert par alain six fois sur dix
c'est la version du sénat qui est adopté
76 % des textes sont des textes de
compromis qui sont adoptées après
négociations entre le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale donc dans 24%
effectivement on aura cet aller-retour
qui fera que peut-être à la fin le
l'assemblée nationale aura le dernier
mot et encore et on a des exemples où
l'assemblée nationale a dû retravailler
complètement son texte pour pouvoir
essayer de le faire passer donc les
exemples sont pas citer l'exemple il ya
des exemples très concrets très concret
la dématérialisation dans chaque projet
de loi que porte le gouvernement
on a désormais un volet
dématérialisation des élus qui
représentent les territoires ce que sont
les sénateurs et sénatrices quand on
leur parle de dématérialisation ils se
disent zones blanches thd fibre qui
n'existe pas sur certains territoires
donc on a aussi cet angle des
territoires de justice territoriale et
ça c'est notre marque de fabrique et
c'est notre intérêt dans la fabrication
de la loi c'est moins politique si je
vous suis bien c'est ce que vous me
dites depuis tout à l'heure c'est moins
politique que l'assemblée nationale
fabien genêt je me tourne vers vous
c'est moins politique gérard larcher
vous venez d'en parler il a été réélu
président on va quand même souvent sur
les plateaux télé donc il ya un petit
peu de politique là-dedans une prise
pouvoir peut-être un petit peu il est
c'est bon heureusement qu'il est sur les
plateaux télé pour expliquer à la fois
l'action du sénat et prendre des
positions mais si vous permettez on a eu
jean tendait le débat très technique
entre mais mes deux collègues qui
siégeait déjà moi je dois peut-être
apporter un témoignage c'est que j'ai
été réélu maire de digoin au printemps
président de la communauté de communes
du grand charles ix à l'été et pour tout
vous dire je n'avais pas vraiment prévu
dans le calendrier de me présenter au
sénat cet été parce que je voulais
poursuivre tout ce que j'avais entamé
dans mes mandats locaux
et il ya un moment à la fin du printemps
début de l'été où je me suis dit quand
même ce serait pas inutile
ce serait pas inutile d'aller à paris
porter un certain nombre de témoignages
et essayer de changer les choses parce
que dans mes actions locales
bien sûr tous on arrive à changer les
choses à changer un peu la vie de nos
concitoyens avec eux mais souvent on se
retrouve bloquée parce que la france est
un pays très administrée avec souvent
ben voilà on se retrouve coincé
finalement par la magouille députés
députés
alors non parce que parce que pour moi
effectivement c'est souvent trop
politisée au sens où on le voit dans nos
départements les députés de la majorité
viennent expliquer à tout le monde
pourquoi le gouvernement fait tout bien
et puis ceux de l'opposition nous
explique le contraire je pense que le
sénat il ya une troisième voie qui
permet de prendre en compte la réalité
des choses et ce qui est important
finalement dans ce mode d'élection du
sénat mes collègues ont bien expliqué
que pour qu'il y ait deux chambres qui
soit utile il faut qu'elle soit élue
différemment sinon il n'y a pas
d'utilité il faut qu'il ya un dialogue
entre elles et surtout le fait que nous
soyons élus par des élus c'est que nous
avons été choisis par des gens qui ont
l'habitude l'habitude d'écouter nos
concitoyens et surtout de proposer des
solutions de construire des solutions
avec les concitoyens localement et donc
les sénateurs ils ont ce lien
particulier avec ceux qui ont déjà
entamé la construction d'une solution et
c'est moi ce que je veux porter en
siégeant maintenant hausse et d'un
pouvoir relayer cette voix des
territoires
parlons un peu concret jérôme durain
dominique vais rien qu'est ce que vous
avez fait pendant vos mandats votre
premier mandat qui a changé la vie des
français moi je pense
un sujet jean n'était pas l'auteur mais
c'est un sujet qui était portée par mes
collègues
martial bourquin sénateur de du doubs et
c'était l'assurance emprunteur c'est une
proposition de loi donc une initiative
parlementaire et il a proposé qu'on
puisse plus facilement changer
d'assurance emprunteur quand ce qui
concerne un certain nombre de français
inquiets quand ils empruntent pour
acheter un bien immobilier
c'était un endroit qui était difficile à
exercer sa représente souvent 30 % du
coût du crédit pour les gens si le sénat
ne s'en était pas occuper si elles
peuvent pas eu cette proposition de loi
on n'aurait pas eu ce droit très concret
à faire des économies sur les assurances
pour les citoyens comme il devait rien
l'exemple que vous avez un titre
personnel j'ai carrément déposées - une
proposition de loi concernant la
fondation du patrimoine qui permet
d'étendre le label fondation du
patrimoine qui va des propriétaires
privés aux communes jusqu'à 20000
habitants alors que jusqu'à présent
c'était réduit aux communes de moins de
2000 habitants ou sites patrimoniaux
remarquables donc là c'est direct mais
je pense aussi à d'autres exemples qui
ne sont pas forcément là non plus de moi
le stage en fin d'études de six mois en
zone sous dotée pour les étudiants en
médecine
voilà une chose que le sénat a négocié
le sénat avait demandé un an l'assemblée
nationale n'en voulait pas la
négociation en commission mixte
paritaire nous a amenés à 6 mois de
stage
ça c'est grâce au sénat grâce au sénat
je pense à marie mercier qui en tant que
rapporteur sur une loi une proposition
de loi au niveau des violences
conjugales a obtenu que quand on est
inscrit au fichier vous savez c'est des
infractions et des violences à caractère
sexuel les auteurs d'infractions à
caractère sexuel que les mis en examen
soit automatiquement inscrits dans ce
fichier ce qui permet qu'on ne les
embauche pas au contact des enfants et
or aujourd'hui le juge avait la
possibilité de le faire mais le faisait
trop rarement
aujourd'hui ce sera automatique dès la
mise en examen en cas de crime
le sénat avait demandé des mêmes pour
les délits la négociation assemblée
nationale sénat a fait qu'en cas de
crime
la personne sera automatiquement
inscrits au fichier sauf si le juge ne
le souhaitent pas utile donc voilà sont
des petites avancées effectivement on ne
révolutionne
même pas on rend des choses possible et
des choses qui sur le terrain nous sont
nécessaires
une classe une classe politique qui
représente pas toujours les français on
en a parlé ça avec les gilet jaune
il ya quelques mois les jets légion qui
proposaient leurs hic le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne est ce
qu'aujourd'hui le sénat il représente
vraiment la population française jérôme
durain oui il la représente
est ce qu'il est et ce qu'il est
population française sans doute pas il
est à dire qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas
encore au niveau en terme de parité on
n'est sans doute pas au niveau sur
toutes les caractéristiques de la
population française en revanche on la
représente pour la raison que nous
écoutons les élus à dire que si le sénat
avait été aux manettes au moment dé
gilet jaune il y aurait sans doute pas
eu gilet jaune
si le sénat ne s'occupa de certains
sujets parce qu'il représente la
population et représenter la population
ça veut pas dire avoir toutes ces
caractéristiques
parce que sinon il ya que des femmes
pour représenter les familles avec des
vieux pour représenter les vieilles avec
des jeunes et ça évolue en plus à
l'aller en sénateurs qui de leurs 26 ans
quand même l'âge moyen du sénateur c'est
quand même 60 ans et un homme de race
blanche fabien genêt vous avez eu
l'impression d'arriver à la maison de
retraite cette semaine au sénat je suis
un peu provocatrice la phrase elle est
pas de moi c'est c'est un ancien député
qui l'a dit les données sont déjà à leur
deuxième mandat on n'a pas du tout ce
sentiment là je crois qu'il faut faire
attention aussi parce que l'intérêt du
sénat c'est aussi de représenter ceux
qui sont peut-être numériquement moins
nombreux mais qui mérite toute
l'attention de l'état de la société
française c'est les territoires ruraux
dans lesquelles nous vivons en
particulier en ce delwart en charolais
numériquement effectivement ce sont des
zones où il ya moins d'habitants qu'en
ville et si on part du principe qu'il y
a seulement la représentation qui compte
ça veut dire que bientôt seuls les
métropoles auront leur mot à dire et moi
ce qui m'a convaincu également de
m'engager
c'est que je sens monter et bien ce
mouvement qui qui m'inquiète parce que
on nous ferme à digoin par exemple on va
nous faire mais la perception
on va nous faire mais le guichet de la
gare il ya ce départ d'un certain nombre
de services publics et peu à peu les
gens sentent bien que voilà tout se fait
en métropole tout se fait à paris et peu
un peu plus personne ne va porter cette
voie il a son mot à dire la cena là
dedans bien sûr parce qu il
la chambre des communes historiquement
parce qu'il leur présente les
territoires parce que nous sommes élus
par les élus bien évidemment que tous
les jours je vais avoir mes collègues
maires au téléphone où je vais les voir
je vais avoir cette embrouille interrogé
aussi le gouvernement bien sûr et donc
une fois que je dirais si et j'ai toutes
les semaines
à paris c'est l'intérêt c'est de pouvoir
relayer ce que moi j'ai vécu comme air
ce que vivent mes collègues et proposer
des solutions est alerté et je vous
ferai observé que sur les gilet jaune
les premiers qui ont alerté le
gouvernement sur la hausse de la
fiscalité des carburants
c'était et sénateurs s'étaient les
sénateurs malheureusement le
gouvernement à l'époque ne l'a pas
entendu mais c'était bien le sénat qui
avait tout de suite senti cette
sensibilité sur le terrain là ce que
vous avez là mais restons quand même que
vous allez pouvoir demi derrière je vous
coupe représente et je vous dis
n'importe quoi la mère de famille de
nevers les jeunes des grésillés à dijon
tout le mécanicien de chalon est ce que
le sénateur ils représentent ces
personnes là le sénat représente
l'ensemble des élus qui représentent
l'ensemble de la population et
finalement par rapport à cette
population des élus qui a besoin aussi
d'être entendu nous sommes effectivement
représentatif
est-ce que souvent un élu et notamment
un élu rural qui peut pas vivre d'un
revenu d'élus et de mer à est un jeune
retraité donc finalement on n'est pas
forcément très éloigné de ce que nous
représentons
politiquement aussi nous n'avons pas un
parti qui à lui tout seul à la majorité
ce qui est aussi un store le débat est
par ailleurs pourquoi est-ce que nous
sommes aussi un peu plus anciens de son
don du coup tous issus en règle générale
nous avons été élus et avant forcément
nous travaillons et surtout quand on est
élu rural
nous travaillons en même temps et j'ai
tendance à comparer le sénateur par
rapport aux députés le sénateur c'est le
parlementaire par l'apprentissage serre
que quand nous arrivons au sénat nous
savons déjà ce que c'est que d'être élu
et que de gérer une collectivité et
c'est très important et ça fait ce
regard complémentaire que souvent non
pas les députés jérôme durain williams
et bien il faut pas qu'on se laisse
caricaturés comme des gens vieux
homme blanc loin de la réalité du monde
j'ai fait un rapport pour effacer les
chiffres j'ai fait un rapport pour le
premier ministre manuel valls est axé le
maire à l'époque sur la pratique
compétitive du jeu vidéo
c'est la première fois qu'on
s'intéressait au jeu vidéo dans une
instance de la république c'est au sénat
on a aussi dans notre territoire des
planning familial qui s'intéressent à
diverger et qui nous contacte on a aussi
des entreprises qui ferment on a aussi
des sujets médicaux enfin toute la vie
elle est dans les territoires toute la
ville et d'un territoire et on
représente les territoires et les gens
qui habitent donc on est des
parlementaires de plein droit mais c'est
à dire qu'on est un peu décalé on n'est
pas sous les feux des projecteurs mais
on fait notre boulot sans chercher la
lumière change sans chercher forcément à
sortir du lot parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'un autre mode d'élection nous met à
l'abri de la tentation d'exister pour
exister
donc on fait notre travail discrètement
mais on fait bien ça vient gêner je me
tourne vers vous c'est une assemblée des
territoires or depuis toujours elle est
détenue au presque par la droite est ce
que c'est pas juste une assemblée de
notables droite aujourd'hui que senna
est ce que vraiment j'ai la tête d'un
notable de droite
non j'étais jeune je crois qu'il ya eu
déjà une alternance donc le sénat a vécu
l'alternance comme le disait dominique
aucun groupe n'a la majorité absolue
donc il ya nécessité de dialoguer et de
pouvoir construire ensemble des
solutions et puis effectivement il ya
cette sensibilité à tous les territoires
et je crois que c'est bien en saône et
loire par exemple il y a deux sénateurs
chalonnais il ya maintenant sénateur du
charolais et c'est pas forcément des
histoires de clivage politique c'est
souvent des histoires de vécu parce que
le développement économique c'est bien
sûr plus facile à chalon sur saône que
dans l'ouest de la saône et loire et
donc il faut assurer cette
représentation mais toujours pour
essayer de construire des solutions
c'est ce qu'on fait comme comme élu
local et c'est vraiment l'idée de
pouvoir le poursuivre au sénat parce que
vous savez lorsque par exemple j'ai eu
des soucis avec mon entreprise de
céramique à digoin je me suis retrouvé
devant 250 salariés à qui on venait
d'apprendre leur licenciement je suis
monté à bercy avec avec les
parlementaires et j'ai été estomaqué
parce que j'ai bien senti qu'à bercy
ministère des finances on avait tiré un
trait sur l'industrie francs
là je me suis dit il faut des
parlementaires qui vont pouvoir défendre
leur industrie c'est la même chose sur
l'agriculture on a des grands sujets
aujourd'hui de désamour entre la société
française et ses agriculteurs les
électeurs du charolais son sont vraiment
estomaqué pas parce ce manque de
confiance donc il ya des choses à
reconstruire il faut des gens pour
porter pour porter ces voix et pour
trouver des solutions
si on vient il ya une question autour de
laquelle vous tourner depuis tout à
l'heure mais vous emporter il y aura
deux ans portait uniquement sur le
scénar est ce que la démocratie
française fonctionne bien est ce que
tout le monde me représenter est-ce que
finalement dans cet équilibre
institutionnel ça marche
non ça marche pas et a beaucoup
d'absents sionisme beaucoup de votes
extrêmes mais c'est pas le seul senna
qui va être interrogé l'assemblée
nationale où on m'a dit par exemple
plusieurs fois on m'a finalement si
l'une des deux chambres qui fait qu'ils
devraient être supprimés c'est
l'assemblée nationale est ce qu'on parle
de la toute puissance de l'exécutif dans
ce pays est ce qu'on parle du rôle
exorbitants d'administration centrale
c'est un équilibre institutionnel et
donc si la question que vous posez c'est
est ce que ça fonctionne bien
non ça ne fonctionne pas c'est bien
est-ce qu'il faut un peu de démocratie
participative
en plus de la démocratie représentative
oui est-ce que c'est au seul senna de
porter tout ça non parce que dans le
rôle qui est le nôtre ont fait le boulot
alors s'il faut que tout bouge c'est la
bougera avec et il sera solidaire on
n'est pas contre la réforme par principe
en revanche il faut s'interroger sur les
vrais mécanismes je pense par exemple
que le lien entre l'exécutif et le
pouvoir parlementaire n'est pas
satisfaisant et que on devrait plus
puissant la commission bensalah prouve
que quand on fait notre boulot jusqu'au
bout
merci le sénat merci gérard larcher
alors on peut mettre le doigt sur de
vrais problèmes mais c'est un équilibre
global
alors on fait ma transition les tout
fait que ce qu'il faut modifier le sénat
dominique vais rien c'est des gens c'est
l'élection c'est plus de pouvoir
le blocage des sites statiques par
exemple ah non je crois que s'il faut
modifier quelque chose c'est au niveau
de l'assemblée nationale parce que le
lien très fort et la chambre qui est
soumise aujourd'hui c'est plutôt
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat sert
justement pousse à négocier avec
l'assemblée nationale et empêche que les
choses puissent passer
sans discussion donc c'est très
important de garder le sénat et après
effectivement il faut qu'on regarde
comment ça s'articule et comment le
pouvoir exécutif doit respecter le
pouvoir législatif
effectivement il a eu un peu de temps il
sait il a mis un peu de temps à le faire
de 2017 à 2018 on va dire que c'était
quand même un peu douloureux mais à
partir de 2018 et je dois l'avouer
effectivement la commission bensalah
nous y a bien aidé on a commencé à
pouvoir discuter négocier pour en
arriver à ce que je vous disais c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui 76% des textes
arrive à être négocié mais ça a été
par force combat est donc le sénat doit
continuer à garder cet équilibre à
permettre cet équilibre entre et cette
discussion entre les deux chambres
mais je pense que le quinquennat est un
vrai sujet en fait le fait de lier
l'élection des députés à l'élection du
président de la république
ils lui sont forcément inféodés ils ne
pourront pas passer si leur présidente
ne passe pas puisque c'est des grandes
vagues donc on sait bien que leur
président est battu la chance d'être
battue est très grande et pour autant
pour autant j'ai peut-être une petite
nuance avec mon collègue de saône et
loire sur la vision de la vème
république il ne semble détonnera pas
moi je pense que quand même un peu de
stabilité dans les institutions ça fait
pas de mal aussi
c'est vrai quoi donc on garde les ans en
france on aime toujours en france
vouloir mettre tout tout par terre un
peu stabilité ça fait pas mal
rappelez-vous l'épisode des gilet jaune
est effectivement le moment où le
pouvoir exécutif a tremblé à tremblay où
vivait ces manifestations à paris qui se
rapprochait de plus en plus de l'elysée
on a été bien contents de trouver à la
fois le sénat et le président la
république a été bien contents de
trouver le président du sénat pour
incarner un peu cette cette stabilité
et puis ensuite le président a été bien
contents de trouver les élus locaux pour
ré asseoir un peu de légitimité et je
pense que dans les années qui viennent
avec la crise malheureusement la crise
économique et sociale qui naît de la
crise sanitaire avec les présidentielles
qui vont arriver
et un paysage politique qui peut être
très largement bouleversé en 2022 je
pense que avoir une chambre de
tempérance une chambre d'équilibré
chambre attentive aux territoires
vous verrez dans quelques mois que nous
serons très très heureux d'avoir d'avoir
un sénat qu'il ya sur cette stabilité
il ya quand même une théorie qui court
avec une chambre qui pourrait remplacer
le sénat avec des citoyens tirés au sort
bonne ou mauvaise idée
moi j'ai pas de pas d'objection
théorique a priori sur ce sujet là
j'entends ce que dit fabien genêt sur la
stabilité la tempérance et jeanjean part
pour moi même ceux de cette analyse il
ya quand même quelques défauts du
système en l'absence d'alternance le
sénat était une fois à gauche pendant
tout pendant trois ans en 2009 et mi
temps c'est pas tout à fait normal quand
même donc c'est qu'il ya un petit sujet
de représentation et par ailleurs on
puisse s'interroger sur ce qui provoque
ces dépenses aient le sentiment d'être
mal représentés ou d'avoir besoin de
passer par les côtés pour contourner le
système est quand même une cave est
quelque chose qui fonctionne mal dans
les institutions donc stabilité hockey
tempérance oui mais il faut qu'on trouve
des moyens par lesquels les gens sont se
sentent mieux représentés est ce que le
tirage au sort est ce que le sénat
stable peut être composé différemment
pourquoi pas on doit pas s'interdire de
réfléchir à ça ça peut être en qui
évolue aussi
mais ils sont quand même il faut quand
même que les élus soient responsables
devant les électeurs et donc le tirage
au sort ça peut ça peut être intéressant
cela garantira pas forcément le hasard
ne garantira pas forcément une meilleure
représentation que ce que peuvent faire
des électeurs ou de grands électeurs
et puis la question c'est acquis on
rencontre derrière et ça moi je pense qu
en démocratie c'est important et on peut
passer des heures et des heures sur la
représentation mais je pense que ce
qu'on vit sur le terrain ce que les gens
attendent
lorsqu'ils choisissent leur mère ils
n'attendent pas que le maire puisse
représenter la totalité des catégories
socio professionnelles ou des groupes
d'âge
qu'est ce qu'ils attendent la mer ils
attendent de l'efficacité quand vous
avez un problème dans votre quartier
quand vous avez un problème de crèches
quand vous avez un problème avec
l'hôpital qui s'en va comme vous n'avez
plus une médecin ce qu'on attend des
élus locaux et donc ensuite des
sénateurs
c'est des solutions il faut remettre en
france aujourd'hui dans le débat public
de l'efficacité et donc la
représentation sévère c'est
effectivement un sujet mais c'est pas le
seul il faut arriver à remettre de
l'efficacité ce qui me permet de
rebondir sur le fait que le sénat
représente aussi les territoires et
particulièrement les territoires ruraux
parce que le mode d'élection fait que
une commune de 40 habitants à une voie
commune commune de 400 et c'est très
important que ces territoires puissent
être entendus or le tirage au sort
malheureusement risque de tomber
forcément dans les villes et par
définition puisqu'il ya plus de monde
dans les villes que dans les campagnes
et donc ça je pense que c'est très très
important de faire un endroit aussi de
garder un endroit où les territoires
ruraux peuvent être entendus et
s'exprimer on est à six mois des
régionales
un an et demi de la présidentielle sur
quels dossiers vous souhaitez vous
engager de dominique vais rien vous
venez de le dire nous sommes à deux pas
des régionales je pense que la loi 3d
qui doit arriver décentralisation
déconcentration différenciation pour nos
territoires est une des lois les plus
importantes
encore faut-il savoir ce qu'il va y
avoir deux dents et en tout cas ça c'est
un des vrais sujets sur lesquels je
souhaite travailler et puis continuer
mon engagement contre les violences
intrafamiliales
fabien genêt quel parlementaire vous
allez être j'espère être un
parlementaire aller coûte parce que ça
c'est important pour bien sentir les
problématiques les sujets à l'écouté
puis capable de proposer des solutions
par rapport à tout
tout ce que je vois sur le terrain ce
que j'ai vécu dans mes mandats c'est ça
qui me motive aujourd'hui avec des
dossiers particuliers j'avais des sujets
bien sûr sûr je parlais de l'agriculture
pour un élu du charolais c'est c'est
naturel il ya vraiment beaucoup pas
faire parce que c'est pas simplement un
problème de paysans c'est un problème de
la société française qu'est-ce qu'on
veut manger comme on veut entretenir de
noter à nettoyer ans qui a tous ces
sujets il faut qu'on arrive avec les
agriculteurs avec les ruraux à trouver
des solutions et puis je parler de
souveraineté industrielle c'est
important aussi parce que je les ai
vécus et puis sur la santé également en
saône et loire avec le président a carry
nous avons construit des solutions pour
pour endiguer la désertification
médicale donc c'est un sujet qui me
préoccupe et qui m'intéresse jérôme
durain quelle vision du territoire vous
allez défendre plus équilibrée et où
chacun
droit à l'égalité républicaine que notre
pays proposent ça passe par les services
publics ça passe aussi par exemple
l'écologie dans les territoires le
rapport à la voiture
quand on est dans une métropole on dit
la voiture c'est pas bien baddou dans
nos territoires ruraux sur n'a pas de
voiture on vit pas donc comment on fait
aussi pour que certaines idées qui sont
dans le débat public
elles atterrissent dans nos territoires
donc ça c'est très important au niveau
au plan local
et puis moi au plan la commission des
lois où je siège je suis très sensible
aux questions de libertés publiques
parce que je pense que on est dans une
période où les libertés publiques sont
mises à mal parce que on serre la vis à
cause du terrorisme à cause de la
situation sanitaire et qu'il va falloir
un petit peu desserré si on veut ta
société respire la question écologique
dans les textes aussi moi j'ai porté le
premier parlementaire à porter le sujet
de l'écocide crime environnemental donc
voilà il ya encore plein de travail
le numérique n'oublions pas numérique
est encore plein travail merci à tous
les trois d'être venus débattre sur ce
plateau ça passe bien dit on on se
reverra pour discuter tout ça dimanche
en politique qui continue dans un
instant francis letellier reçoit le
ministre de l'agriculture julien de
normandie ce sera juste après votre
flash d'informations régionales tout de
suite avec les manuels pinsonneault
merci d'avoir été avec nous très belle
journée sur france 3
[Musique]